So I'm going to start talking about the second
part of the data wrangling, normalization,
and preprocessing of text, which is followup
of the talk given by Professor Picone two
weeks ago in which he expressed the deep learning
methods that are used to process the signal.
So clinical encephalography, or EEGs, as I'm
going to call it from now on, is known to
be the most important investigation in the
diagnosis and management of epilepsies.
An EEG records the electrical activity along
the scalp and measures spontaneous electric
activity of the brain.
And for that, it is the main test for brain-related
illnesses.
In my talk, I'm going to show how, along with
the EEG signals, we are processing the EEG
reports which are documenting the interpretation
of these signals.
So I'm going to show the kinds of methods
that are used in order to process the clinical
text in the EEG reports.
So data wrangling is defined as the process
of mapping data from an unstructured format--
in this case, the narratives of the EEG reports--
to another format that enables automatic processing,
and in this talk today, why do we need to
see how that format is basically a very complex
annotation schema that enables us to do two
kinds of processing-- one, to organize the
information of complex probabilistic graph
that would enable probabilistic inference,
and the other one on which I'm going to focus
more is in representing these EEG reports
and the signals into multimodal index that
would enable us to perform identification
of patient cohorts.
So the ability to process the narratives in
electronic medical records, which are now
collected in every hospital in the country,
would also give rise to the identification
of a staggering wealth of biomedical knowledge.
This knowledge will be inferred not only from
the abstracted text, but also from many measurements
such as vital signs or multichannel signal
data-- as in our case, it's provided by the
EEG signals.
So we believe that this information could
be transformative if properly harnessed.
So as I'm going to be focusing mostly on processing
the clinical test, we are going to see that
current state-of-the-art natural language
processing need to be enhanced with deep learning
methods that face the challenges which are
posed by the complexity and the volume of
big data repositories of medical records.
So I'm going to show how combining the advantages
of two kinds of learning-- namely, active
and deep learning-we will be able to process
a large collection of EEG reports and annotate
with the clinical concepts and their attributes,
which will enable us to create an EEG-specific
qualified medical knowledge graph, and also
to be able to use that for medical inference,
like estimations of likelihoods of the clinical
correlations or interpretation of EEG test,
and also in the discovery of patient cohorts.
Now, when we talk about clinical text mining,
this has been done for many decades.
And there's ample research that can be distinguished
in mining the biomedical literature-- for
instance, trying to find medical concepts
in medical journals, medical textbooks, and
scholarly research reports, or in another
case, mining the clinical notes-for instance,
radiology reports, progress notes, surgical
notes, or hospital discharge summaries.
These two kinds of clinical text mining are
quite different because the first one focuses
on biomedical NLP that extracts genes or proteins
or pathways and biomedical events and relations,
which gives an opportunity for translational
work in biomedical natural language processing--
with other words, getting results from the
biological domain into the clinical domain.
When we perform clinical NLP, we're actually
focusing on building profiles of individual
patients by extracting a broad class of medical
concepts and conditions-- for instance, the
diseases, the injuries, or the symptoms and
signs, as well as responses like the diagnosis,
procedures, treatments, and drugs.
And the goal here is to improve patient care.
So the talk today will focus on clinical NLP
processing.
I want to point out another special case of
performing clinic NLP, which is for aiding
computerized clinical decision support.
And there's an excellent article authored
by Dr. Diana Demner-Fushman, Wendy Chapman,
and Clement McDonald that is offering an excellent
survey.
The title of this article is "What Can Natural
Language Processing Do for Clinical Decision
Support?"
Well, let's look at what are the steps of
clinical and classical natural language processing
of electronic medical records.
As we see, we first need to identify what
are the medical concepts that we want to annotate
or discover in the medical records.
In addition, because these narratives in medical
records are often using [INAUDIBLE], we need
to identify the assertions.
Are these medical concepts factual or are
they negated?
Are they expressing some hypothesis?
After we identify the medical concepts and
infer the assertions, the next step is to
discover the features that would enable us
to recognize them automatically.
The features are informing some classifiers
that would be trained and will be able to
annotate automatically the medical concepts
in the records.
The results of these classifiers also need
to be evaluated, and the cycle continues.
Well, there's very interesting work and excellent
resources on discovering medical records and
natural language processing.
And there was a challenge in 2010, for instance,
that aimed at recognize automatically in records
medical problems, medical tests, and treatments.
So we wanted to take advantage of this past
work and understand that recognizing such
concepts involved two decisions.
First of all, you need to identify the boundaries
of these concepts-- with other words, what
is the first word in the
narrative where the concept is mentioned,
and what is the last word?
And after you recognize the boundaries, well,
what kind of medical concepts have we recognized--
with other words, what's the type classification?
Is it a problem, is it a test, or is it a
treatment?
So the problem is and the challenge is that
we are facing when we need to annotate big
data is that this time, we're having to annotate
many more types.
There are resources that perform wonderfully,
for instance, [INAUDIBLE] that would identify
in medical records any concept that is annotated
in the Unified Medical Language System.
However, there is not coverage for any kind
of EEG-related medical concepts there.
So we have to go and look at other annotations
that we can provide for the specific type
of records.
As many more types of medical concepts will
need to be discovered in big data that would
infer that we'll have to have a very large
number of classifiers, and that poses an incredible
challenge because those classifiers will need
to have some optimal feature selection, and
it is very difficult to do that throughout
a large number of classifiers.
So the solution comes from deep learning and
active learning.
And by combining deep learning and active
learning, we're actually generating a multitask
active deep learning paradigm that aims to
perform concurrently multiple annotations
of all the EEG activities and their attributes,
or the EEG events, or the medical problems,
medical tests, and medical treatments that
are encountered in the EEG reports.
Well, what are EEG activities?
These are brain activities such as waves and
patterns.
And what they are the EEG events?
These are brain responses as direct result
of a specific sensory, cognitive, or [INAUDIBLE]
event.
In addition, with the identification of every
medical concept of these types, we want to
identify their modality and polarity values.
What are the possible values of modality?
It's factual, possible, or proposed, which
indicate whether that clinical concept is
an actual finding or is it possible finding,
or a finding that may be true at some point
in time in the future.
And polarity has a value of either positive
or negative.
On the lower-hand side of this slide, you
are seeing that basically, the annotations
that we are performing are of multiple types.
And for instance, in the case of an annotation
for an EEG activity such as rhythm, we have
a lot of attributes, like this is a rhythm
with a frequency band of alpha, and it is
located in both hemispheres, and it is recurring
continuously, and the location is occipital,
and the modality is factual, and the polarity
is positive.
So with this, I am exemplifying the complexity
of the many types and the many attributes
that we need to annotate in a set of very
large number of EEG reports.
So what's in an EEG report?
When an EEG report is created, it follows
the American Clinical Neurophysiology Society
guidelines for writing such reports.
It has to start with a section on the clinical
history describing the patient age, gender,
and the relevant medical conditions and medications.
Then an introduction section is discussing
the
EEG technique or configuration, followed by
a description of the notable waveforms, activities,
patterns, or EEG events from the signal.
Then a mandatory section is the impression,
which is interpretation, whether the EEG indicates
normal or abnormal brain activity, and a list
of the contributing [INAUDIBLE] phenomena.
And it ends with a clinical correlation section,
which relates the findings with the overall
clinical patient picture.
So when annotating a big data of EEG reports,
we had to create a schema such that we could
describe all the semantics of the EEG activities
and events as they are discussed in the report.
So the first question that we had to answer
was, well, what medical concept do we really
need to annotate, and what are their types?
We decided to annotate medical problems, treatments,
and tests, as well as EEG activities and events.
And you see here our first example.
For instance, if in the clinical history we
are reading recently seizure-free but with
episodes of light flashing in her peripheral
vision followed by a blurry vision and headaches,
we want to be able to annotate the fact that
seizure is a medical problem, as well as episodes
of light flashing in her peripheral vision
is a medical problem.
As you see, this problem for these medical
concepts can be mentioned as a single word,
seizure, or a sequence of words, like in episodes
of light flashing in her peripheral vision.
In the following section, Topamax is identified
as a treatment.
Now, when we go to the description of the
record, we are seeing that sharply controlled
delta activity is actually an EEG activity.
So is spike complex.
But around these activities, we have a lot
of other attributes that are expressed, like
the fact that the sharply controlled delta
activity is frontally predominant and it is
irregular.
So we need to capture, also, these attributes
of the EEG activities in our annotation schema.
As we know [INAUDIBLE] EEG activities are
not mentioned always in continuous expressions,
we decided to use a schema in which we will
annotate the anchors of EEG activities, and
the attributes will be determined as a followon.
What kind of attributes we decided to capture?
Well, we decided to capture a very large number
of attributes.
The most notable one is the morphology.
The morphology represents the type or form
of the EEG [INAUDIBLE].
You see here that on the right-hand side of
the slide, I'm showing the semantic hierarchy
of the values that express the morphology
of the EEG activities.
They are classified as rhythms.
They may be transient.
They may be a single wave, like for instance,
wicket spikes.
They may be complex.
And as complex waveforms, they may be spike
and sharp wave complexes or sharp and slow
wave complexes.
But they can also express a large variety
of patterns, like suppression or like a periodic
lateralized epileptic form discharges.
The morphology is just one of the attributes,
along with several others, that describe the
general attributes.
We also have temporal attributes and spatial
attributes that we want to annotate.
The frequency bands represent the second attribute
that we annotate that distinguish whether
the waveform is an alpha, beta, delta, or
theta or gamma form.
We also want to annotate whether this is in
the background or not.
And as general attributes, we also annotate
separately the magnitudes, which describes
the amplitude of the EEG activity.
Among the temporal attributes, we are annotating
the recurrence-- showing how often the EEG
activity occurs.
And the possible values are it's continuous,
repeated, or if it is none, that means that
it occurs only once.
The EEG activities are also associated with
a significant number of spatial attributes,
and they are grouped in three categories.
The first category is the dispersal attributes,
which describe the spread of the activity
over regions of the brain-- could be localized
or generalized.
The second type of spatial attributes are
the hemisphere where it occurs-- could be
right, left, or both-- and finally, in a [INAUDIBLE]
spatial brain, the brain location, which has
another number of attributes describing whether
it's frontal, occipital, and so forth.
So as you see, we have a total of 16 attributes
that are associated with each EEG activity,
which makes for a very complex semantics of
the annotate schema.
So how would these annotations look like?
In this slide, you see an example of the manual
annotations of the EEG reports that we have
performed to create training data for our
deep learning architectures.
In this example, you see two types of annotations.
The blue annotations represent the boundaries.
For instance, multiple sclerosis indicate
that that is a mention of medical concepts.
In red, you see the actual type of the medical
concept.
So here, we see it's multiple sclerosis, it
is a medical problem, it is having the modality
of factual, and it is having the polarity
of positive.
But please note when we go into the introduction
section how the annotations become more complex
because, for instance, in the case of the
EEG activities, like spike and wave discharges,
in red, we see all these values of the various
attributes that are associated with it that
need to be annotated, like the morphology
is transient, it is a complex wave in the
form of spike and slow wave complex with a
frequency band of delta, not in the background,
with a magnitude normal, that recurs as repeated,
the disperse is generalized.
We don't have information about the hemisphere,
but we have information about the location
as being frontal.
And the modality is factual, and the polarity
is positive.
I want to note that in this annotation, we
are actually making sure that we're attacking
two important text processing problem-- namely,
the ambiguity and the economicity of text.
Ambiguity means that we may have one annotation
that may end up expressing different semantic
points in the hierarchy.
And economicity means that in this specific
EEG report, there's no place where it's indicated
that this is a frequency band of delta that
we need to infer because later on, we're basically
seeing that the notation is from 4 to 4.5
hertz.
So you'll see it's a very
complex annotation schema that tries to capture
the wealth of semantic information that is
described in the EEG report.
So let's see how we can create some machine
learning architectures that would enable us
to automatically annotate a very large corpus
of EEG reports following a schema.
First of all, we need to preprocess the EEG
reports because there's many very important
resources for medical language processing
out there.
So we use the GENIA resources, which comprise
a tagger for tokenization-- tokenization means
identifying every word in the narrative--
lemmatization, which means every word is transformed
into its base lemma form, the part of speech
which recognize and that this word is a noun
and this words is a verb, and so forth, as
well as phrase chunking, which means how the
words are grammatically sticking together
in a phrase.
We also use the widely popular resource, which
is the Stanford CoreNLP, for detecting syntactic
dependency parsing.
In addition, because every token or word in
the EEG reports were identified, we created
the Brown cluster features from the entire
Temple University Hospital cohorts.
The Brown clustering is an unsupervised learning
method that discover hierarchical classes
of words based on the context in which they
occur.
We also made use of the Unified Medical Language
System to create feature vector representations
that capture the medical knowledge that is
available from this system.
Then we have decided on two groups of features.
The first group will be used in the deep learning
architectures that identified the EEG activity
anchors, as well as the boundaries of the
EEG events, medical problems, medical tests,
and medical treatments.
We have decided on seven different features.
The first one would be the lemma of the token
and the previous and the next tokens.
The second feature is the part of speech of
the current token and its previous and next
token.
The third feature is the phrase chunk in which
that token belongs.
The fourth one is the lemma of the current,
previous, and next token.
We made use of a feature that represent the
Brown cluster in which the token is situated,
then the UMLS concept unique identifier for
that token, and the title and the section
of the EEG report where the token is observed.
In order to detect the EEG concept type, the
attributes, the many attributes of the EEG
activities as well as the EEG concept, modality,
and polarity, we decided on another set of
nine features, which are listed here-- the
clinical constant mentioned, the lemmas of
each token, the part of speech, the lemmas
of the three tokens before and after, the
title the section, but this time also used
syntactic dependency paths, the number of
words between the clinical concept mentioned
and the specific token, the number of hops
in the syntactic dependency path, as well
as the number of clinical concepts between
the clinical concept mentioned and the token
in question.
So that corresponded to that block in the
natural language processing cycle in which
we had to decide on the features that best
represent the clinical concepts that we want
to annotate in a vast resource of records.
So once that we have the features, we have
to go and decide on the deep learning architectures.
Two weeks ago, Professor Picone discussed
a lot about the art and the magic that is
involved in deciding on the best architectures
that you want to use.
Deep learning is the preferred machine learning
techniques that can be used in the face of
very large collections of text-- in our case,
a very big resource of EEG reports.
So here I'm going to start discussing the
first architectures that we used to identify
the boundaries and to identify the anchors
of the EEG activities.
The boundaries were identified for the EEG
events, the medical problems, the test, and
the treatments.
So in order to decide the architecture that
is best suited to be able to learn how to
automatically identify these boundaries and
anchors, we have decided to use two architectures--
one for the EEG activity anchors, and the
second one for the boundaries of the other
types of medical concepts that we were aiming
to annotate.
These architectures, as you see on this slide,
are represented by stacked long short-term
memory cells, and they are stacked because
they are having several layers, and we represent
it in this architecture as entries of the
tokens.
So you see t1, t2, t3, tn corresponds to the
tokens of every sentence in any section of
the EEG report.
The output of the architecture [INAUDIBLE]
is labels b1 to bn-- one label bi is associated
with the token ti.
The label values are i or b.
A label of b indicates that this word is the
beginning of a mention of a clinical concept.
A label of i indicates that this word or token
is inside the mention of the clinical concept.
And the label of o indicates that this word
is outside of any kind of clinical concept
that we want to annotate.
So let's go a little bit in more detail on
how this deep architecture, the neural architecture,
actually work.
So by considering each of the tokens in each
sentence, we want to predict the labels that
they should be associated with.
Therefore, we have a better representation
of the token from the sentence.
You might be asking yourself, what is in this
vector representation?
Every token is associated with all the features
that we have decided we want to use-- so the
[INAUDIBLE] values for that specific token.
And what is the output [INAUDIBLE] is values
for the labels in, out, or beginning of a
medical concept.
I want to know the fact that each of the long
short-term memory cells in this architecture
is also using a memory state that is shared
throughout the network.
For instance, on the first layer, the LSTM
cell receives an input from the vector of
the token.
So let's take token number 2.
That vector will be input to that LSTM cell,
which also gets as input the memory from the
previous LSTM cell and produces an output
which becomes an input to the next layer,
and so forth.
So we have such three layers that make sure
that they are propagating all the features
from the current token, as well as the previous
tokens, to the soft-max layers that decides
the labels that should be associated with
every
word.
So we use these three labels.
And on the soft-max layer, we are actually
producing a probability distribution of the
possible labels of values i, o, and b.
And this is accomplished using a vector of
all the probabilities of a label to be an
i or a label to be on o or a label to be a
b.
Therefore, the soft-max layer is predicting
what is the highest probability of a label
that should be associated with that token.
So this architecture enables us to identify
and to annotate the EEG activity anchors and
the boundaries of all the other medical concepts.
But we still need to understand what are the
attributes associated with this EEG activities
and what are the types of the other medical
concepts, as well as what are their polarities
and modalities.
This is accomplished by developing two other
deep learning architectures.
So you see in this slide that we have one
architecture that would identify all the attributes
of these EEG activities, or the 16 ones that
we have discussed before, as well as the modality
and the polarity.
The second architecture is identifying a type
of medical concepts divided into medical problems
or EEG events or treatments or test, as well
as the modality and the polarity.
You can note that these architectures are
very different because of the fact that this
time, while using a deep rectifier linear
network, which is using itself five fully
connected layers of rectifier linear units,
so why we decided on using this architecture?
Why does it work very well?
And how does it really work?
The decision of using these fully connected
layers of rectifier linear units was based
on the incredible properties that these units
provide.
So I'll call them ReLU from now on.
So ReLUs are known that they allow for a very
easy deep net configuration, but they also
have a sparse representation that allows them
to perform de facto internal [INAUDIBLE] selection.
With other words, when you learn this multitask
embedding in this architecture, you are actually
learning a selection of the optimal pictures
in identifying each of the attributes of the
EEG activities or in identifying each of the
types of medical concepts that you want to
annotate.
So these 16 attributes are identified by feeding
with shared embedding into a separate software
layer for each of the attributes, and the
same thing happens for the two software layers
of identifying the medical concept types and
their modality and polarity.
So instead of training tens of classifiers,
we're actually having only two deep learning
architectures that perform very accurate annotations
on a very large set of EEG reports, and they
do that with learning the optimal features
that need to be selected.
Well, as we develop these two types of deep
learning architectures, we want to incorporate
them in the active learning loop.
The active learning loop starts with this
vast collection of EEG reports on which manual
annotations were performed.
And I've shown you examples of how they look
like.
But those annotations become initial training
data for the two types of deep learning architectures
that we just presented.
These architectures then are used to annotate
the thousands and thousands of EEG reports
automatically, and then we need to have some
sampling methods to decide which of them we
should present to a neurologist expert for
validation and editing.
And this enhances the initial training sessions,
and they annotate the entire corpus again.
I want to note here on the right-hand side
that the active learning loop is the one in
which you have an expert going and validating
the results of the deep learning annotations
and provides new retraining data.
And in order of making the best use of the
expert, you need to develop some sampling
methods.
And the sampling methods that we have developed
are taking into account that we are making
many types of annotations, as we needed to
combine a rank combination protocol that would
combine the single task active learning selections
into one.
For this, we developed a usefulness core for
each unvalidated annotation from the EEG reports
and calculated it with the kind of rank it
would allow to have the highest usefulness
to the neurologist experts.
We also experimented with some Shannon entropy
in developing these sampling methods.
So the sampling methods enabled the usage
of the active learning, which will be more
accepting and editing the annotations, and
then retraining the deep learning methods
and evaluate the new system.
How does it work?
Well, on the left-hand side here, you see
the learning curves of all the annotations.
So if you take, for instance, the first 100
EEG reports that were annotated and evaluated,
you see that, for instance, that the boundary
detection very quickly improves from-- we
start from an F-score of 85%, and we very
quickly go to about 90% only from a small
set of 100 reports.
The EEG anchors being more complicated, it
is interesting to see that we start, again,
from an F-score of around 86%.
The quality decreases initially, but it increases
after a very small set of annotations.
The attributes which were not expressed in
the anchors and morphology are showing the
greatest increase.
They the most complex ones.
And we start from a low score of around 67%
F1 score, and we get to almost 75% F-score
in very few number of annotations, which is
also expressed by the activity attributes
learning curve.
Now, once the EEG report annotations are being
produced, what are we going to be able to
do with them?
We are looking at two possible applications.
The first one is to create an EEG-specific
qualified medical knowledge graph which can
be used for medical question-answering as
a clinical decision support, as well as for
various medical probabilistic inference problems,
like learning the posterior distribution of
clinical correlation given an EEG description.
Alternatively, the EEG report annotations
enable us to create a semantically rich index
of clinical EEGs, and also incorporate the
EEG signal data in order to retrieve patient
cohorts.
So I'm going to focus on the second application
now.
The EEG report annotations would enable us
to create this semantically rich index because
for every medical concept that we automatically
identify, we can generate a separate unique
identifier.
Along with the identifier, we'll generate
the concept type.
For instance, this is an alpha activity, or
it is a sharp and slow wave.
And if it is a concept that uses multiple
terms, then each term would receive its own
term ID.
For the EEG activities, we'll also organize
all the attributes and the terms that I used
to express those attributes.
That would generate what we call a medical
concept dictionary.
These medical concept dictionaries can also
be associated with their IDs into a term dictionary
because in information retrieval, we generate
term-based dictionaries.
So every term ID that was found associated
with every medical concept ID would be expressed
in the term dictionary, and that's where we
associate the polarity that we have discovered,
along with the concept in which the term was
used.
Any time we have a positive polarity, we'll
indicate what EEG report that term was found,
in which section, in which position in the
section, what was the medical concept ID in
which it appeared, and what was the actual
concept and their modality, if it was a negated
concept that it represented with similar information,
but in a different list.
In information retrieval, we use dictionaries,
and also posting files.
So now I'm going to put my information retrieval
researcher hat on, and we'll discuss, well,
how can we search for relevant patients, and
how can we really be able to use this index
in the best way?
So we first need to create inverted tiered
lists.
So what are inverted tier lists?
They make sure that every time when you find,
for instance, a concepts like a seizure, it
would be able to know all of the EEG reports
in which they are encountered.
So we'll have tiered inverted lists for every
positive polarity indication of seizure, as
well as another set of inverted lists for
every negative indication of a seizure in
which you see that we have the term dictionaries,
like seizure, but we'll also know that that
specific term belong to a medical concept
ID-- in this case, a medical problem that
is encountered in some EEG report.
But as you remember from two weeks ago, Dr.
[INAUDIBLE] showed that these EEG reports
are associated with every EEG signal and their
processing.
So we'd like to be able to also use this other
modality that shows the actual tests, and
we created some EEG signal fingerprints that
are also linked into the tiered inverted lists
that would enable us to search for the patients
that we are interested as based on the criterias
of the cohorts.
The EEG fingerprints are also organized in
a similarity hierarchy.
So how does this work?
Well, the EEG fingerprints are generated by
taking into account that the EEG signal includes
this floating-point matrix based on the number
of electrode channels that were used, as well
as the number of samples in the recording.
So when we did one pass over all the EEG signals,
we found that this requires an enormous amount
of information.
Just for one signal, we would need to have
more than 400 gigabytes of information.
Therefore, for the multimodal index, we have
to consider a more compact representation
of these EEG fingerprints.
This compact representation was created by
another deep learning architecture.
So now you see a third exemplification of
big learning in which all the EEG signals
are processed in a very short time.
Instead of processing them in weeks and weeks,
we are processing them in matters of hours
because we reduced the EEG signal from 20
megabytes to just a few hundred bytes.
That was possible by using the recurring neural
network that you see on this slide in which
we consider that every EEG signal is actually
a sequence of samples such that for every
sample, we'll learn how to predict the next
sample.
And this was made possible by using, again,
the long short-term memory cells that would
learn longrange interactions in the EEG signal.
So the long short-term memory cells maintain
an update in internal memory such that they
can output the EEG fingerprint after they
look at all the samples.
So once that we have created this complex
multimodal index, we can answer natural language
queries that express the criteria for a patient
cohort.
For instance, if a neurologist would like
to find a query of patients that take Topiramate,
Topamax, with a diagnosis of headaches and
an EEG demonstrating sharp wave spikes or
spike [INAUDIBLE] wave activity, the deep
learning methods that process the clinical
texts would be able to annotate this query
and recognize that Topiramate, Topamax are
medicines, and that headache is a problem,
and the EEG is a test, and sharp wave spikes
and spike [INAUDIBLE] are EEG activities.
Once that the analysis of the query is being
performed from the EEG cohort description,
we'll be able to use two relevance models
that take into account the term or the concept
dictionary that we have discussed, as well
as the inverted list to enable the recognition
of patient cohorts.
So we experimented with two cases-- one case
in which we used only the annotations on the
clinical texts, and another case in which
we augmented those annotations with the index
that considered the signal, as well-- therefore,
the multimodal index.
And we were pleasantly surprised that this
relevance model showed that the multimodal
index produced the better cohorts.
So in order for [INAUDIBLE] these cohorts,
we had to develop relevance models.
In informational retrieval, there's this BM55
ranking function that enables you to find
the most relevant documents or EEG reports
that would match a certain query.
If we are considering also the signal fingerprint,
then we had to develop another relevance model
in which we could look up the most similar
EEG fingerprints for the top rank reports
provided by the BM25 ranking function.
So we asked, then, several neurologists to
provide with a patient cohort descriptions,
which we call queries, and
here you see five examples of descriptions
that they all agreed that would be of high
clinical interest for them.
And then we passed those queries through our
patient cohort retrieval system and asked
them to evaluate the results.
So for every patient cohort criteria, we identified
the 10 most relevant EEG reports, and then
we did a random sample of 10 other reports
that were retrieved between the ranks of 11
and 100.
Each neurologist was asked to judge whether
each of the EEG report was considered relevant.
They would give a rank of 1 if the patient
described in the report definitely belong
to the cohort they were looking for, and a
0 if the patient does not belong to that cohort.
And then we used three measures that are widely
accepted in the information retrieval community
to evaluate the quality of the results.
These measures are the mean average precision,
the normalized discounted cumulative gain,
and the precision at rank 10.
And here are the results.
So if we would have used only the clinical
EEG reports with no processing of the medical
concepts, then we would have obtained a precision
of, then, at about 80%.
And as you see the map, which we have defined
the mean average precision would be only about
52%.
If we would have used some language models
in which we would have tried to create a similarity
based on statistical properties between the
query and the EEG reports, actually, the mean
average precision would have been even worse.
And as a third baseline, if we would have
used just simple text processing, the median
average precision would have been 46%.
Therefore, in less than half of the cases,
the patient would not have been relevant.
Our multimodal patient retrieval system, which
we call Mercury, obtained much better results
because we were able first to introduce the
medical concept dictionary.
So we obtain average precision of 58% to 57%.
When we also introduced the signals, this
average precision jumped to 70%.
But I also want to note this other metric,
which is the precision at 10, which means
the 10 most relevant patients.
And please note that in the case when we used
the signals as well as the processing of the
EEG reports, [INAUDIBLE] in a precision of
100%, meaning that the first 10 patients are
always evaluated as should have belonged to
the cohort.
When we have used only the automatically produced
annotations on the EEG report, the precision
at 10 was 90%, meaning that out of 10 patients,
nine should have been in the cohort, and one
is incorrectly included in a relevant cohort.
So as summary, I hope that I have convinced
you that using deep learning on big data can
be transformative because active learning
can take advantage of [INAUDIBLE] successful
deep learning architectures and approaches
to produce annotations, and in the case when
adequate sampling mechanism are considered
in the active learning loop.
Also, neural learning enables a large number
of annotation tasks be performed jointly and
provides a very rich semantic information
to be captured in a global manner across vast
clinical resources.
We believe that deep learning can play an
important role because data [INAUDIBLE] critical
because there's lack of annotated data, and
there's many applications which will not support
the development of annotated big data resources--
they are developed for a small number of reports
and a small number of types of concepts that
we aim to annotate.
Annotations is just an enabler for many applications.
For instance, searching through newly annotated
data, we also have to consider all these modalities.
Sometimes, we have text narratives, but we
also might have other kind of signals or images
associated with them.
The clinical information needs to be organized
into a multimodal index, which can be generated
with novel deep learning representations.
The annotations produced with deep learning
in vast clinical data will enable the generation
of probabilistic representations of medical
knowledge, which will give a new impetus to
probabilistic medical inference.
I want to acknowledge the grant that made
possible our research.
This is research supported by the National
Human Genome Research Institute, the National
Institute of Health, and the Award Number
1U01HG008468.
This research wouldn't have been possible
without the incredible corpus of EEG reports
and signals from the Temple University Hospital.
Any opinions or conclusion and recommendations
are only the authors' and do not reflect the
views of National Science Foundation or National
Institutes of Health.
And if you want to find more about me or you
want to learn and read the papers that I have
discussed here, please go to this URL that
you see on this slide.
And here are some papers that I touched on
when describing the methods here.
The first paper that describes all these active
deep learning architectures has been submitted
to the Clinical Research Informatics at AMIA.
The second paper was just presented in November
at the Annual Symposium of AMIA.
If you want to know more about the corpus,
please go and visit the Temple University
Hospital EEG Data Corpus, which was published
in the Frontiers of Neuroscience.
And if you want to find more about how natural
language processing can be applied to medical
question-answering for clinical decision support,
we had a paper this fall in the CIKM Conference,
which was awarded the Student Best Paper Award.
And we also have an upcoming paper on using
deep learning from EEG big data for inferring
underspecified information in EEG reports.
So I would be glad to take questions now.
So hi, [AUDIO OUT] Harabagiu.
Thank you so much for being with us here today.
You're taking time away from your day job
as professor, and we really appreciate it.
This work is fascinating.
It seems like it's very much related to your
big data knowledge grants.
I'm wondering what other applications do you
see of this because certainly, the methods
that you've talked about and the usage of
deep learning and all these different-- in
multiple ways for the same problem, towards
the same goal, but using it multiple times,
seems to be a very novel way of doing things,
same problem, towards the same goal, but using
it multiple times, seems to be a very novel
way of doing things, but yet also very-- could
be applicable in other [AUDIO OUT] of applications
or types of problems.
What do you see doing next after this?
What do you see as the next step?
Well, what I would be interested is in using
these methods and probably developing new
methods to be able to do clinical decision
support and being able to identify how all
these annotations can be used to inform questionanswering
methods that are trying to find similar cases
in literature, especially as we have so many
publications being generated on a monthly
basis and could inform a clinical decision
support.
Another important application would be this
creation of a very vast probabilistic knowledge
base and sharing it with the community, especially
the machine learning community that is in
big need of having the resources to apply
for probabilistic inference and creating factor
graphs that would be able to give us priors
of all these clinical correlations and of
similarities between patients.
Another application that we have discussed
with our friends at Temple University is the
ability to detect in real-time seizures.
And this kind of very complex probabilistic
knowledge base would be able to inform very
much these predictive methods that we could
develop on data that we annotate in any kind
of corpus.
This is not necessarily related to EEGs.
Any kind of corpus that would have any kind
of clinical narratives and would have eventually
any kind of other modality, like images, could
be processed with [INAUDIBLE] same methods
with a little extra work of tweaking the annotation
schema to the specific problems that that
corpus is covering.
I'm glad you mentioned that one of the next
steps is doing the inference on here because
one of the questions online is about how you
account for uncertainty, but in particular,
how do you account for the uncertainty in
the data as it's collected, or that is collected.
Exactly.
So we know that this data is not perfect.
So it may contain errors, and it has a lot
of uncertainty, definitely.
So there are two ways that we have in mind.
So the first way that we study [INAUDIBLE]
is try to infer the underspecified information.
So there's a lot of clinical data that is
not giving you the full picture.
So there's a lot of underspecified things
that are not discussed that you want to discover,
as well.
The other aspect of it is that once that you
have this probabilistic knowledge base, you'll
be able to start using a probabilistic inference
on it to be able to deal with uncertainly.
In the knowledge base that we are constructing,
we are associating these modality values.
We have more than these three that I have
discussed here.
We have several attributes which are values
of uncertainty, like is this hypothetical,
is this possible, is it associated with another
patient, and so forth.
And all of those kind of certainty values
coming from the inferences that I detected
in the narratives, I used in probabilistic
inference to generate the most likely outcome
that you are looking for from this very vast
knowledge base.
Thank you.
There's another question online, or a couple
of other questions, really about which kinds
of tools are you using in your research, and
tools or data.
So for example, are you using IBM Watson or
other tools?
Are you using PubMed Central's corpus as your
data?
If you could just say a little bit more about
the types of things that have been helpful
to you?
OK.
So that's an excellent question.
So first of all, we are using clearly for
question-answering, we are not using Watson
because I have a past work in question-answering
for about 20 years.
I'm one of the authors of a book on question-answering.
So in my lab, there's a lot of expertise on
building question-answering systems.
We believe we can do it better because we
have our own tools of relevance of natural
language processing and the ability to identify
and pinpoint complex questions and their answers.
So these are our own tools.
And we actually want to share them with the
research community.
These tools are now upgraded with these deep
learning methods-- some of them I have described
here.
The deep learning libraries that we have used
were TensorFlow from Google.
We experimented with several others, but we
all settled on TensorFlow because we find
that they are very reliable and very well-documented.
Also, in terms of other natural language processing
method that we are using, we are using the
GENIA corpus.
We make use of UMLS.
We make use of the PubMed Central archive
in order to tune the features that turn out
to be most informative to our methods.
And by the way, we would like to release a
version of the patient cohort retrieval in
such a way that anyone could build their own
patient cohort on their own clinical data,
and also to release these kind of multimodal
indexes that people can easily use in their
research or experiments.
Thank you very much again.
We're out of time, but I just wanted to say
that on behalf of everybody online who is
muted and can't talk that we really do appreciate
you coming and sharing a bit of your expertise
here.
And it was certainly fascinating to hear about
the use of deep learning to automatically
annotate the EEG reports and to retrieve relevant
reports.
So thank you.
Thank you, Michelle.
Thank you for giving me the opportunity.
All right.
Goodbye, all.